in this video I want to let lab rate
about secondary structure secondary
protein structure and in the last video
we sort of introduced the idea of
secondary structure I mentioned two key
things and those were the Alpha helix or
alpha helix ease right and beta pleated
sheets okay and we mentioned that it was
important to understand that we're
thinking about hydrogen bonds
oops hydrogen bonds holding these two
themes together and the hydrogen bonds
exists specifically between
the backbone of the polypeptide right
not the R groups we're not considering a
hydrogen bonds involved for the R groups
we're just considering the ones between
the carbonyl groups and the amide
hydrogen's right so this is the hydrogen
bond that we're concerned with right so
how does that come into play with alpha
helix and how does it come into play
with beta pleated sheets well let's
begin our discussion with the Alpha
helix so what should we know about an
alpha helix first thing that we should
keep in mind is that it's a right-handed
helix and what does that really mean if
you hold out your right hand point your
thumb up and to turn your hand sort of
tool or turn your wrist towards your
fingers and causing your fingers to
point upwards and you know kind of
create a helix that way if you do that
with your left hand you would see that
the direction of the two heel is just a
little bit different details behind that
I don't personally feel are incredibly
important to sort of to to understand
you know what an alpha helix is but it's
a good thing to keep in mind that it is
now a right-handed helix okay and there
are plenty of details about off of HeLa
C's including how many peptides that
there's one polypeptide for helix how
many amino acids there are per turn all
kinds of crazy things but I kind of want
to just talk about you know the things
that are I think are key to to
understanding you know
now Felix is so well it is a helix right
so let's think about it being a helix
looking like this let's draw it out kind
of like this right if we imagine this
what I'm drawing here to be a
polypeptide chain right so each little
section here this string here is a
string of a bunch of amino acids it's
tons and tons of amino acids okay so
this this structure would have to be
held together in some fashion right well
we expect it to be held together by
these hydrogen bonds this is what I'm
sort of getting at here so the hydrogen
bonds that exists along this this helix
well first I want to mention that the
axis of the helix is you know up and
down like this so just imagine this this
you know this dotted line here if you
will right this is the axis of the helix
okay okay so what we have here excuse me
is we're going to have hydrogen bonds
existing sort of sort of like this where
we might have you know a hydrogen bond
here right and then a hydrogen bond here
and then the hydrogen bond here and then
a hydrogen bond here holding this helix
together okay so each one of these
little the lines here as a hydrogen bond
now we mentioned that the hydrogen bonds
are between the backbone so when I want
to mention this over here we have we
have hydrogen bonds between the carbonyl
and the amide hydrogen every fourth
amino acid so every fourth amino acid so
we have one amino acid here four amino
acids later in the in the chain we have
that fourth amino acid hydrogen bonding
with this this one here right likewise
over here and here and here so these
eight H bonds are sort of holding this
helix together okay
something to just bear in mind is that
these h-bonds right specifically are
parallel right they are parallel to the
axis of the helix right these these
these lines here these are h-bonds
they're running parallel to the axis of
the helix okay that's something to keep
in mind okay one more thing I feel is
imperative to keep in mind is that what
are the R groups doing where are the
side chains where where are they in this
sort of mess
the R groups of the amino acids are all
pointing outwards somehow obviously not
going to be able to draw them all but if
we have our groups they're going to be
pointing out of the helix like this okay
so these are all the side chains right
now this is obviously not the best
drawing if you go on to conducting a
google image search you'll find you'll
find these uh you know images of these
Gila sees and I'm sure they're much
better than what I can draw here but
it's a just sort of give you an idea of
what's going on with an alpha helix so
if we have some sort of really really
long chain of amino acids at some points
we might find you know a helix here and
maybe maybe between amino acids number
50 and 100 you might see a couple out P
lyses and then we might not see another
alpha helix until like you know maybe
between amino acids 101 and you know 200
who knows right but the point is that
we'll see that if you if you kind of
conduct a google image search of the
structures of proteins you'll find that
you'll see many many alpha helix sees
and you'll also see beta pleated sheets
sort of coming into play one more thing
I did want to notice or do want to
mention about alpha helixes is that
they're usually mentioned about
sometimes when they talked about they
talked about how the the alpha helix is
a dipole right the alpha helix is a
dipole in which one end will be the
let me let me draw this in a different
color the the n-terminus will be the
will be the Delta positive end right
because the night the amino terminus has
a positive charge and though the
c-terminus will be considered the Delta
my's the the the end that has the
partial negative charge okay so so if we
think about this this could be the the
end terminus right and this could be the
carboxy terminus right so this would be
the Delta positive and Delta minus end
okay so this is what sort of what an
alpha helix is like now what things
could disrupt this alpha helix what
things could mess this up right let's
talk about that okay so let's talk about
things that can disrupt or ruin an alpha
helix okay so there are there are plenty
of things that can do that one thing I
want to mention first and foremost is
the amino acid prolene right prolene if
it's somewhere in this alpha helix it
can mess it up and the reason why is
because if you recall prolene right it's
restricted in its rotation because of
the fact that it's our group binds back
to its amino amino group right so it's
rotation is restricted due to its R
group right and I'll kind of draw that
out in just a second right
another thing is quite simply that it's
alpha amino group right oops
I don't want to draw it like that I want
to write out the word amino it's alpha
amino group does not have an H available
available for hydrogen bonding alright
so let me kind of draw this out quickly
for you so if we have an amino acid here
this is call it our one amino terminus
here and then it's connected to prolene
let's kind of draw prolene out so if we
draw a prolene right here right it's
going to look like this right when that
when when this binds like this right
prolene right this nitrogen here does
not end up having an H that it can use
to hydrogen bond so um so that in these
hydrogen bonds wouldn't be able to exist
to hold together the alpha helix so if
prolene is somewhere and then alpha
helix that's a problem so it's going to
disrupt it or if there's like a mutation
that you know substitutes a prolene in
for an amino acid that wasn't prolene
and it should be that you know prolene
could ruin that protein structure
because where there should have been an
alpha helix that might no longer be one
okay so prolene could definitely damage
this damaged an alpha helix okay
another factor is is if there are
electrostatic repulsion sore attractions
electrostatic repulsion from amino acids
with charged side chains or with like
charged side chains okay so let's say
there's an arginine next to an arginine
okay so arginine next to an arginine so
example here an example arginine next to
an arginine both of these are going to
have positive charges as we know
positive charges or or if like charges
repel right so
so if they're somewhere near each other
where they're supposed to be an alpha
helix then bending away from each other
could compromise the alpha helix right
another example would be you know
aspartate and aspartate right an
aspartate near another aspartate if they
both have negative charges
they'll repel right so if they're
repelling each other within where
they're supposed to be an alpha helix
that could compromise you know the
ability of these hydrogen bonds to form
where they're supposed to form okay so
that could damage the V alpha helix cuz
those hydrogen bonds need to form in
order for the structure to sort of be
maintained okay another thing is just if
there are if there are bulky side chains
okay so steric hindrance right steric
hindrance right let me sort of underline
that underline this from this is Zahra
Kendra's caused by bulky side chains
being close together close to each other
right so if there's like a phenylalanine
right which has an R group that's that
you know the R group for phenylalanine
looks like this it has a ch2 and then
you know oops this you know benzene ring
here that that's huge you know so
phenylalanine next to another
phenylalanine right if they're both next
to each other that could be you know
that the bulky side chains right might
you know they take up space and if they
they're taking up space they might not
that could cause you know this this this
string to sort of kind of go out of
whack and and again allowed the or cause
a disruption these H bonds being able to
form
okay so that's something that could also
disrupt the alpha helix
okay so I wanna I like to end the video
there and continue to talk about beta
pleated sheets in another video which I
will make in just a second
alrighty thanks for watching guys